congressional correspondent chad program
is live on capitol hill hey chad
hey there well you know democrats are
very concerned about forging ahead
with this confirmation process
especially the news we heard about the
president today republicans are saying
no
no this isn't going to lay delay
anything here's a statement i'm going to
read you from chuck schumer the
democratic leader
and the top democrat on the judiciary
committee dianne feinstein
they say quote it's premature for the
committee to commit
to a schedule when they don't know the
potential exposure from the president's
infection
now republican utah senator mike lee
announced he is positive he met with
barrett on tuesday
barrett is being tested daily and she
tested negative
senate judiciary committee chairman
lindsey graham says concern
about infections won't sideline the
barrett hearings
he told president trump that today by
phone
and so we're on track we're going to
start october the 12th
and we're going to work hard to get this
wonderful conservative
young lady talented
beyond belief amy barrett on the supreme
court
now it's unclear what this hearing would
look like with these health concerns
here at the u.s capitol would they have
the senators beam in remotely like
they've done with other hearings we're
also being told
that the office of the attending
physician is now testing members and
staff who may have been exposed that's a
key
issue here and again we talked about
hiccups this is the type of hiccup
that could delay the senate from
considering this nomination
before the election dana all right but
it sounds like lindsey graham says it's
on track so we'll keep an eye on it and
we'll keep in touch with you chad thank
you